protesters take cover under a bridge in
central Baghdad as gunshots ring out
scenes like these have led to strong
political reaction religious leaders and
politicians are taking the protest
movement seriously the Speaker of the
Parliament Muhammad Ali Hall busi is now
publicly backing the movement where we
must pay tribute to all the young heroes
whose weapons were their words to convey
their message to all the institutions of
the Iraqi state for the need to proceed
with real reform and the need to pay
attention to the people's livelihood
influential Shia cleric muqtada al-sadr
also issued a statement saying that the
government should be dissolved and new
elections held the Iraqi Prime Minister
our loved al-mahdi appealed for calm but
his words are seemingly having little
effect promises by the prime minister
are to fool the people and they are
firing live gun shots at us
this was a peaceful protest they set up
these barricades and the snipers sitting
right there since last night
Ali al-sistani issued a letter which was
read out by his representative Armadale
sloughing not a man we hope that the
voices of reason and logic can prevail
for the best interest of the country all
the officials have the responsibility to
make the right decisions to move forward
everyone should be aware of the danger
of excessive violence before it is too
late the government says it's listening
to protesters demands and will hold an
emergency session on Saturday one of the
main political bloc's Fatah also issued
a statement saying the government must
implement sweeping reforms within ten
days other political bloc's have
boycotted the parliamentary session
saying it doesn't have an agenda it can
implement therefore a part look the
protesters demands
the age of the protesters has surprised
many in Iraq but with a young and often
unemployed generation it's perhaps
unsurprising that frustration has turned
to anger and anger into violence the
trend seems to be that the protests are
intensifying and and certainly they will
they will continue I think one question
is whether the Arbaeen celebrations or
processions coming up might have some
effect on breaking the momentum but
certainly the the there is a lot of
momentum behind these protests in
Baghdad there are checkpoints every few
hundred meters and mobile patrols drive
through the streets tension on the
streets remains high several countries
have warned s citizens against travel to
Iraq neighboring Iran has shot two of
its main border crossings with the
country and the United Nations has said
that the government must open a dialogue
with the protesters but given no protest
leaders have emerged it's unclear who
they'll open that dialogue with imran
khan al jazeera baghdad